Speaker 1: It's great to welcome to the program
today, David Liss, who is a health services
researcher at Northwestern University. He
conducts research to improve the quality
and value of primary care delivery. David, it's
great having you on today. Thanks for having me.
So, you know, in the context of Obamacare, but
also more generally, there's the discussion of of
preventive health care, the idea that it's cheaper
to prevent or treat something early than it is to
wait until it becomes more serious. I think that
intuitively makes sense, too, to a lot of people.
But that can take sort of a lot of different forms
and shapes. One can be you go into the doctor
every year and they feel around, listen to your
lungs, et cetera. That could include doing regular
blood work, cholesterol, complete blood count, et
cetera. Then there's also other types of screening
starting to do PSA and prostate exams for men at
certain ages, colonoscopies, mammograms, etc. So
there's all this different stuff. How can we start
to kind of categorize these things and think about
the impact on people's people's health from them?
Speaker 4: Well, I think well, at least what
we do here in the research world or in those
sort of medical care world is that there's an
organization called the U.S. Preventive Services
Task Force, and that's been around for a while.
And but what the Affordable Care Act did is that
it took services that are recommended by this
group, the USPSTF, as we call it, and services
that are recommended by the by this group are now
fully covered under pretty much all or certainly
most insurance plans that people have. So we're
talking about some of the things you mentioned.
There are things like colonoscopies and colorectal
cancer screening mammography for women age 50 to
74 recommended vaccinations, et cetera. So there
are many services that have been shown. There's
clear benefit that can help people live longer,
healthier lives. And there has been this group
of researchers who has really sifted through the
data continues to pore through it every two years,
and they find that these are beneficial services.
Other things like prostate cancer screening
that I think you may have mentioned PSA test,
even these kind of routine lab tests. A lot
of those services aren't actually recommended
to be done regularly, maybe for some high
risk patients, but for your average or low
risk patients. Some of those services are not
recommended by this group and aren't necessarily
covered for free through your insurance plans.
Speaker 1: Yes. So you know, there's this idea of
what is it that we're trying to do like with a
general health check. And one answer would be,
well, we're trying to diagnose something earlier
in order to control it. And then a subsequent
question, I guess, would be OK if we do that, are
we improving quality of life or extending life?
And I guess the answer is not always yes. It
kind of depends on what we're doing, right?
Speaker 4: It depends, yes. But again, there are
a lot of kinds of screenings we can do, a lot
of kinds of risk factor checks that can be done
where again, if you catch it early and there are
available well known treatments, you can certainly
be extending life and quality of life. Now the
problem there is that there, if you're doing
things that aren't necessarily recommended,
maybe again, that could fall in the range of
things like PSA tests could be things like
routine labs. There is a potential for a lot of
these false positives as you walk, maybe the test
find something and it's potentially worrisome and
leads to this sort of cascade of testing lots of
worry on the part of the patient. Additional
testing, and sometimes all for no reason,
offer sometimes for false positive mammography
that happens sometimes. So what we what we try
to do sort of in the research world, the medical
world is find a balance between whether three,
as we've heard, I think sometimes when we think
about the vaccination debate for COVID, where do
the potential benefits outweigh the potential
harms? And again, there are several services,
certainly colorectal cancer screening being
one where the potential benefits certainly
clearly outweigh the potential harms. One of the
Speaker 1: things I read, and I'd be interested in
hearing what your research has shown are your take
on it is that a lot of the things that are done
that are kind of in the cardiovascular
under the cardiovascular umbrella
don't seem to actually reduce an individual's
chance of having a heart attack. What
is? Can you talk about that a little bit? Is that
true? What does it even mean to say that?
Speaker 4: Well, what I what I certainly
can say is that some of the bread and
butter things we think about most,
most stereotypically checking your blood pressure
know obviously that all of our Typekit that's
perhaps the most are certainly one of the most
important things that can happen in terms of
helping people identify a health problem and
getting it under control. Many highly effective,
inexpensive treatments that can help prevent
heart attack, stroke, death, et cetera. Some
of these other, maybe more exotic kind of tests
again, doing a lot of digging, doing a lot of
tests that aren't necessarily recommended. Again,
that's what we're talking about. The potential
harm could outweigh the potential benefit.
Speaker 1: When we talk about the annual
physical for a second and we have the parts which
are a discussion where you might mention symptoms
or answer lifestyle questions, and then you have
the physical exam, which, depending on one's age,
varies and then you have here are the blood
tests or other things that I want you to do
everything. But the physical exam could be done
virtually. What do we know about the what do we
know about the importance of the part that's
happening in person with the annual physical
versus the other? And of course, once you're at
a certain age and there's a, you know, a prostate
check that obviously cannot be done virtually.
Speaker 4: So you're right. A lot of these sort
of elements of these visits could be
done virtually. What I would also say
is that what some of our research has shown
Richard's research really clearly shows is that
the physical exam is a comprehensive
physical is not necessary. Hmm.
What has been shown to be clearly effective and
I think you alluded to there is we're talking
about lots of screenings, lots of risk factor
checks. And again, as you said, a lot of that
could be done virtually could be done even on,
you know, can sometimes be a questionnaire on your
computer. Things like screening for depression,
screening for problem drinking, screening
for smoking or tobacco use. So much of this,
these kind of screenings can be done virtually.
What were the I think what's interesting, what
we'd like to learn is what can be done really
well virtually. What are some good models to
do that virtually? Certainly, there's a lot of
work that can be done, but let's say you do find
a patient is depressed. Now, if you've done that
screening virtually, how can you connect with
them and get them in to get recommended care
or and or, you know, things like blood pressure
screenings, if someone's experience that it
certainly they could be doing it if they have one
of these blood pressure cuffs, that could be that
could be used at home. That said, it's not always
so simple, and I think it'll be really interesting
to see what are the balance. What what can we
clearly find that can be done well consistently
at home or virtually versus what things need
to be done in office? And how do we sort of
get that sort of division of labor worked out?
Speaker 1: One of the things that seems like it
might make it more difficult to ascertain sort
of health outcomes and health status might be
that people who do the annual physicals, maybe
folks that are already more likely to maybe make
healthier lifestyle choices or maybe eat a better
diet or whatever the case may be. Is it possible
to separate that out to really talk about the
impact just of the physical and the screenings?
Speaker 4: So there's a I think maybe a couple of
things you mentioned there, let me again go first,
go back and say these physical exams themselves,
we don't really need these comprehensive physical
exams yet, as you said, John, as well, these
visits these check ups, as I like to call
them. Oftentimes what we find is that people who
are most likely to get these checkup visits are
people who have gotten them previously right. For
that group, we found the potential benefit isn't
as great as people who might be sort of height
from higher risk groups. And for those folks who
aren't necessarily as motivated, I would certainly
encourage them to sort of think about getting one
of these checkups. But from a from the perspective
of a health care system or a health system,
that's where we need to do a little bit better
work in terms of identifying those patients
and finding ways to get them and finding ways to
help them understand the need to come in and the
benefits for coming in. Or if it doesn't involve
coming and doing some sort of a virtual screening,
meeting them where they are and doing one
of these checkups, because that's where
a really checkup visits have you think, have
the most value people who haven't necessarily
been well connected with the doctor who might
be overdue for preventive services, whether
that's cancer screenings, vaccinations, etc.
Speaker 1: It's often mentioned that there are
people who believe that the reason that a lot of
these things are suggested, etc. is a desire from
medical practitioners to avoid lawsuits to say,
Hey, listen, I did my part, I did everything I'm
supposed to do. We're going to add stuff, and the
more stuff we add, the more likely it is. I can
say I didn't commit malpractise. I did everything
I was supposed to do. In your experience,
how valid is that concern or that assertion
about the entire preventive care world?
Speaker 4: Certainly not. I would certainly
not agree with that as it relates to the
entire preventive care world because as
we spoke about a couple of minutes ago,
when we talk about for what most insurance
plans are going to cover with zero co-pay for
patients as a result of the Affordable Care Act,
we're talking about these high value recommended
services that have been screened and are in our
reviewed every few years by this panel of experts.
And these are shown to be consistently high
value services. Now that's there is that we
need to strike that balance. We don't where I
come out and I say we want people to come in for
checkups and get some of these recommended high
value services. Where it's good is that again,
they're covered with zero co-pay. Most people are
not going to have to spend a dime to be getting
these services that their checkups, their cancer
screenings, their vaccinations, screening for
depression, et cetera. Some of those lower value
services, some of the things that people, as you
mentioned, might be sort of more skeptical wolf. I
think some of those things, there is a reasonable
skepticism and some of those things the experts
have shown there isn't good value to those. But
for the typical checkup covered
by your typical insurance company,
we're talking about high value services that have
been shown to be effective and again aren't going
to cost people money to be receiving them.
Speaker 1: Related to this, and I don't know
if you can say anything about this at all, and if
not, that's fine. When we talk about the dental
cleaning and now we're talking about dental health
number one, there's research into the connection
between dental, health and general health, which
seems to be pretty compelling. And number two,
it seems that in that case, we're really talking
about something with very specific benefits,
where in all of this does the dental cleaning
every six months and with or without X-rays, which
I know is a big source of controversy for some?
Speaker 4: Yeah, I I don't have much expertize
there. So and my research doesn't really focus
on dental cleaning that much. But as you said,
I've heard that there's a lot of research showing
that dental cleanings are associated. I believe
with good kind of cardiovascular and heart
health outcomes, which is quite interesting,
probably relates to some issues as it deals with
things like inflammation in the body, right?
But also maybe speaks to the fact a little
bit of how sort of siloed sometimes health
care is in the United States and that a lot of us
health insurance coverage is separate from dental
coverage. And those aren't maybe necessarily
as sort of harmonized or as comprehensive as
they should be in the dental care area. But
again, regular checkups sound I know is a
is something that is recommended for
dental care, and it has been shown to
be associated with good overall health outcomes.
Speaker 1: A very, very interesting. We've been
speaking with David Liss, who's a health services
researcher at Northwestern University. He conducts
research to improve the quality and value of
primary care delivery. Really appreciate your
time and sharing your insights, David.
Speaker 4: Thank you. It's a pleasure.